[Music]
last year the vikings made a gutsy move
by plunking 84 million fully guaranteed
over three years and the coffers of kirk
cousins we're gonna do a draft now with
free agency just eight days away and as
a practical matter we'll know by next
monday where those pieces are going to
start to fall together if not sooner
here are and we're going to draft these
some gutsy moves that teams should make
with the off season here whether it's
free agency whether it's trade whether
it's anything the free agency window
opens the trade window opens everything
next wednesday so chris that's what
we're going to do today and we have now
accepted rock scissors paper as the way
the coin toss is dead rock scissors
paper is now the way to determine the
first i don't like that i think rock's
paper scissors should only be an
in-person thing i think that's
completely crazy that we're doing this
but okay fine all right you ready yes
are you ready here we go all right rock
rock paper scissors paper
yeah you got there yeah i got to stop
doing something more than
than uh scissors especially because one
of these times is only going to come out
with one finger and you know which one
it would be you need to readjust your
whole approach there it's rocks paper
scissors shoot that is universal i don't
know where you came from with this rock
scissors paper you're you're wrong okay
you know what's funny when you say
when you say rock paper scissors you say
rocks when you get all flustered about
it you say rocks paper scissors it's
rock scissors paper that's what it is
that's what it's always been and that's
what do we have to do a poll on that now
yes we have to tack on to the proper
temperature for cooking a steak pole a
cottasyl that gets into whether it's
rock scissors paper or rock paper
scissors yes we do let's see well i'm
going to then please
get that result you are egregiously
wrong i don't know anybody on planet
earth that does it your way it's always
me right your nose rock baby
okay here we go here we go you ready
okay go ahead bold move number one here
we go oh
oh aaron rodgers
goody as they call him up there the gm
for the green bay packers trade away one
of those first round picks goody i want
a bold move and i want you to trade one
of those first round picks to the new
york giants and i want odell beckham jr
with oh aaron rodgers and oh i would be
a packers fan if that happened because
that would be amazing my favorite
quarterback my favorite wide receiver on
the same football team i mean come on
does it get any more bold than that
rogers and beckham together i mean
that's just like fantasy dream come true
it's reality dream come true but you're
talking about you know arguably the
great the best receiver in the game with
the quarterback who yes is dealing
dueling it out with patrick mahomes is
the best quarterback in the game but
certainly would be an unbelievable
combination and aaron rodgers has never
had this type of weapon at his disposal
that's where i just think it would be
fun rogers dancing around the pocket
scrambling throwing 40-yard lasers to
odell beckham jr i mean come on you know
you want to see that
well i got three quick points here first
it's going to take more than a
first-round pick to get otto beckham jr
away from the giants and it's going to
and the contract is free for the first
round but yes the contract's favorable
but they could give up a first round
pick but it's going to take more maybe a
two maybe maybe two ones who knows maybe
they have to give up next year's first
round pick to make it happen secondly
the last time that odell beckham jr
played at lambeau field didn't go so
well i guess as long as they keep them
off of a boat that should improve
and third third and this is the most
important point yeah i've gotten a text
from my wife right she says it's rock
paper scissors yeah of course of course
your wife has brains i mean of course
she knows it's rock paper scissors
i mean she's only made your wife is
awesome she's only made one fatal flaw
in her whole life yeah and that was very
important other than that she's been a
perfect human being to society
and and uh so you win i'm still going to
put the poll question out there because
i want to see how big of a landslide it
is all right i have plenty of ideas here
and and i've got a really good one i'm
going to sandbag because i don't think
you're going to think of it i'm going to
start with a very obvious one that isn't
being discussed but but you and i have
brought this up from time to time as it
relates to how the steelers have dealt
with le'veon bell it was a concern last
year if they had removed the franchise
tender and put him on the open market
during the season we just saw the ravens
cut alex collins last week after he got
into some trouble off the field hey
ravens go get le'veon bell let's take
this steelers ravens rivalry to the
highest possible level you team le'veon
bell up with lamar jackson are you
kidding me what a combination that would
be lamar jackson throwing him some short
passes out of the backfield opening
everything up down the field defenses
wouldn't know what to do give me lamar
jackson while he's got three years left
on that low-level rookie contract spend
the money on le'veon bell load up the
cannon and let's go for it wow i i'm
just i'm disappointed you did that
because that was going to be my night
you stole that from me last week when i
said that le'veon bell the ravens that
would be awesome
i think that's you got that from me huh
um
yes i'm incapable of thinking of
anything on my own all of my ideas come
from you pretty much except except for
words that's pretty much what i thought
okay that's good well i guess the the
big thing is there i mean the ravens can
they fit him underneath their salary cap
but i do like that move i mean obviously
because i just said i was gonna pick it
too it would be very uh fun to watch
first of all in the division right as
far as the baltimore ravens the
pittsburgh steelers the rivalry that
will just only intensify things and hey
come on if you got lamar jackson
as your quarterback to add a weapon like
le'veon bell to where now teams really
have to worry about bell between the
tackles and oh no bell doesn't have it
there goes lamar jackson off the edge
and then le'veon bell splitting of
receiver uh that certainly would be a
lot of fun to watch so i'm not
disappointed with you there uh i i was
actually gonna go somewhere along the
same lines and i don't even care i'm
gonna use the same player i was going to
say le'veon bell
philadelphia eagles that's what i want
to see a bold move done right there i
mean in state crime it's pennsylvania on
pennsylvania crime he goes across the
state to philadelphia to join the
most recent super bowl champs in that
state and that is the philadelphia
eagles join him with carson wentz we
know there's some running back issues
there with the philadelphia eagles right
darren sproles up in age jay ajayi not
gonna be there anymore
uh you know again corey clement banged
up not special le'veon bell for a team
that wants to run rpos and do all of
those things wow that would be a
great just i think combination between
carson wentz le'veon bell the doug
peterson style offense le'veon bell has
a certain style and swagger about him a
lot like lesean mccoy did in
philadelphia i think he would be loved i
think that's a bold move i would love to
see howie roseman make
yeah and and there has been at least one
report linking the eagles to le'veon
bell came out yesterday on the athletic
the jets the eagles and one other team
were mentioned as the primary candidates
for le'veon bell i still think it's
going to be the jets i've always thought
it was going to be the jets i think the
jets for football and non-football
reasons because they want to compete
with the patriots in the division they
want to compete with the giants in their
own stadium but if the eagles want to do
it and i know i did a spot every
wednesday last year on wip in
philadelphia and until the trade
deadline came and went one of the topics
every week was is there any way the
eagles can trade for le'veon bell well
next week they can have him with no
trade compensation whatsoever if they're
willing to pay him and if they can find
a way to pull it off all right
this next one is somewhat unrealistic
but it's near and dear to my heart i
think you know where i'm at oh gosh here
we go here we go
i i i look at it this way i
and i know that mike zimmer believes
that kirk cousins is going to step up
and have a great second season with the
nfl with the vikings rather i i
okay fine maybe he will
but
they've seen what nick foles can do up
close they've been on the wrong side of
what nick foles can do and they have
enough weapons on that team then i think
a guy who has taken a team to the top of
the mountain could go into minnesota and
really make an impact now
i i would say that they should trade
kirk cousins and sign nick foles the
problem is
you're not going to find anybody to take
kirk cousins unless you do a brock
osweiler hot potato deal where you give
somebody a draft pick to take 58 million
fully guaranteed over the next two years
but whether it's the dolphins whether
it's the jaguars whether washington
won't be able to afford it whether it's
the giants maybe you could find a team
that would just and now the vikings will
they won't do it they'd never do it but
this would be gutsy because it would
involve admitting a mistake because
they're never going to come out and say
hey man we really got it wrong this guy
stinks they're never going to say that
even if they believe it i think there
may be some guys in that locker room
that are wondering what they really have
with kirk cousins there would be no
wondering what you have with nick falls
and i got to do it yesterday on twitter
a little bit with pete prisco because
he's not a big fan of the jaguars
signing nick foles look i don't know why
under why nick foles is so underrated
and that's good for him because he
doesn't have to look anywhere from
motivation you know tom brady's got to
constantly scour for any little
indignity that he can find nick foles no
matter what he does the people doubt him
and i think they're going to keep
doubting him and he's going to keep
thriving and that would be a gutsy move
unload cousins and go get nick foles
yeah okay i get you there i mean i think
that's a little crazy uh certainly i
mean you're being bitter towards uh one
guy on your football team you're being
i'm being appreciative toward nick foles
that's what i'm being you've always been
that i get that what was the pushback
about people not like liking the nick
foles the jacksonville jaguars i just
would like to hear that while we're in
this segment what what was that
yeah pete pete prisco who works for cbs
sports he made the argument that it's
better to spend far less on teddy
bridgewater than to spend the money that
it will take to get nick falls although
i don't know what bridgewater can do he
had a chance to showcase himself exactly
right week 17 and it was horrible yeah
exactly and nor was it that great when
he was healthy before his leg injury i
think people need to remember you were a
vikings fan yeah they went to the
playoffs one of the years it wasn't
because of their offense and teddy
bridgewater it was because they didn't
turn the ball over and they played great
defense and that's go ahead what yeah i
there there were occasions when teddy
bridgewater had to move the ball and he
could i always thought adrian peterson
hampered teddy bridgewater's development
because there was so much of a reliance
on hand the ball to adrian hand the ball
to adrian and they were really hoping in
2016 right before that injury happened
that bridgewater would hit a higher
level of performance and there were
indications that was going to happen he
was great in the preseason game that
opened that new stadium against san
diego on a sunday afternoon in august of
2016 not long before that horrible knee
injury but against seattle in the
playoffs in 2015 right before blair
walsh missed the chip shot he drove the
vikings down the field and got him in
position there was a thursday night game
against the cardinals he led them back
he was capable of doing some good things
he just didn't have to because the
offense at that point was so focused on
adrian peterson yeah oh okay i get you i
mean yep you named two things he did
there for two years that i i get that i
just think that's like an incredible
risk to your point uh especially for a
guy who had to deal with a horrible leg
injury and did not play good in week 17
where teams are going to look at that
film and go whoa like we can't bring
this guy in here to be the starter and
we talked about yesterday with you know
i know we're getting off topic here a
little bit with jacksonville they're in
win now mode they need a guy that can go
in there and and run the run the ship
the right way and nick foles can do that
and we've seen him you know executing a
lot of big moments all right i got one
more point
no no we're having so much fun with this
draft that we're out of time we gotta
hold round three so you got more time to
come up with your final pick we're going
to finish the draft when pfd live
continues right after this
we're only able to jam the first two
rounds of today's draft bold t bold move
a team should make this offseason chris
so far has the packers getting obj via
trade with the giants the eagles signing
le'veon bell i've got the ravens going
after bell and the vikings dumping kirk
cousins and picking up nick foles chris
you're on the clock yeah i almost gave
the packers le'veon bell too and now
that i think back about it i wish i
would have done that just made the aaron
rodgers all-star team that would have
been fun but i spread the wealth with
the eagles and i would like to see it
and i know there's a real possibility
okay i'm gonna do another one here that
i think would just be a lot of fun too
and you know there's rumors out there
that it could be a possibility but i
would love to see this rivalry have a
little more gas thrown on the flames
uh stats
love to see earl thomas to the san
francisco 49ers okay him
team up with richard sherman once again
uh and then i mean in the nfc west you
already have the 49er seahawks rivalry
you already have richard sherman who's a
little pissed off at the way things
ended with seattle now you add earl
thomas into that mix who we know is not
happy about
seattle not trying to find a way to
extend them last year let alone where
things are at this year so i think that
would just make the nfc west which is
already getting to one of those
must watch divisions between the three
young whippersnappers and kingsbury
shanahan and mcveigh versus the old wise
man and pete carroll but this would
certainly stoke the flames of that niner
seahawks rivalry very bold move and bold
pick by thy chris sims to end the draft
and win it's not there
everybody's already talking about that
one this needs to be bold not obvious i
think earl thomas the 49ers has gotten
to the point where it is obvious now the
cowboys have fallen out of the equation
so i throw your challenge flag on the
notion that that's a bold move here's a
bold move this would be bold if it would
happen right and this is one of those
where at first blush it makes sense then
you start thinking about it and it
doesn't but then you think about it more
and it does this is inspired by the
discussion we had earlier in the hour
about who is worth more in trade antonio
brown or josh rosen how about this how
about this
antonio brown plus mason rudolph from
the steelers to the cardinals for
josh rosen plus larry fitzgerald bring
him back to pittsburgh end his career
there i know he probably didn't want to
do it but that's an etsy material to me
having fun
what would the steelers really benefit
from right now could you imagine larry
fitzgerald walking into that locker room
appreciating ben roethlisberger
something he just said the other day and
also you got rose and who you can
develop behind roethlisberger and it's a
reminder to ben hey ben there will be a
future without you at some point so
don't think you run the show now just
because you won this showdown with
antonio brown if you didn't like mason
rudolph coming in last year as a second
rounder you sure ain't gonna like josh
rosen coming now so it's a nice little
shot across the ballot ben you're having
the quarterback position maybe taken
care of post-roethlisberger the
cardinals get a b who will make that
offense more exciting throw kyla murray
on top of it with david johnson oh my
gosh and then you bring in that
leadership from lawyer fitzgerald back
to where he started his football career
as a member of the pit panthers i love
that move it will never happen but my
god wouldn't that be a great move for
both teams i win the draft that was a
that that was a good creative thought
i'll give you that that was fun for the
draft certainly i mean it's about time
you added something to this show so
thanks for showing up finally
your tool here but that was that was
that is a pretty good idea yes
far-fetched certainly but like not like
totally insane you kind of made some
sense in the trade
as i'm thinking about it i'm like this
is no this is ridiculous it's like well
maybe it's not you could make the
argument for every guy moving from that
team to the other team yeah no it's not
it's not the dumbest thing i've ever
heard you say
that's a low bar i would like to see i
mean that would be worth rosin and
roethlisberger dealing with each other i
think that could be the the price of
some money to watch too i don't know how
those two would get along that could be
kind of fun
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports